what you're hearing is the sound of
grass burning in a dense forest in
northern california
it's full of coniferous trees brush and
shrubs
and tons of branches and tons of dried
out foliage because the area is so dried
up thanks to the
warming climate as you walk around you
can hear the crunching
of the branches crunching of leaves and
everything so it's dry and hot and there
are a bunch of people here the ones who
set the spot on fire and keely ryan a
national geographic photographer
observing the scene
and as they're walking around dripping
fire out of their torches which
basically look like
giant oil cans kind of the fire drips
out and forms a thin little line and
they're able to create these lines of
fire and the fire spreads downhill
keely then watches the fire creep slowly
burning leaves and branches as it goes
maybe the flames get as high as six feet
at the maximum um as they kind of climb
up these bushes and
these small trees and open up big areas
in the forest underneath the main canopy
some of the people leading the burn are
members of the yurok tribe carrying out
a tradition that's been practiced for
thousands of years here in their
ancestral homeland
they're training fire lighters to carry
on the tradition
they're learning an important thing
which is how to heal the land they're
learning how to
have a relationship with fire and land
again and they're starting to understand
that that relationship with fire means
that it's not about mastery and control
but it's about moving with nature even
though the world around them is going up
in flames everyone is calm they're
working with the fire not against it
what you don't see is all of this
background knowledge that everyone has
in their heads their mental maps what
was going on was completely different
than mine right because they're looking
at what's going on and they they know
they know exactly where that fire is
going they have that entire landscape
mapped out in their heads and they know
where that fire is going where it's
going to end and where the fire is going
to be burned too by the end of the day
yeah yeah and that speaks to you know
the level of knowledge that these people
who've been working with fire for
millennia basically have had right
yeah yeah absolutely because i know i
grew up in an era when smokey the bear
was all the rage you know with national
parks right and smokey the bear was
always the thing where you were smokey
was like you know only you can prevent
forest fires
like uh yeah by burning
i'm eli chen and this is overheard a
show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at natgeo and
follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week we'll talk about fire
it's not just that agent of destruction
that smokey kept warning us about it's
also a necessary element that heals
natural spaces keeps wildfires at bay
and gives people and animals food and
resources to live
and we'll learn about cultural burning
an indigenous practice that the us
government suppressed for decades and
how climate change an increasingly
disastrous wildfires in the west have
made its revival critical to our future
more after the break
but before we get on with the episode
thanks for listening if you like what
you hear consider a national geographic
subscription and get exclusive access to
stories published daily curated
newsletters and 130 years of archives
subscribe today at natgeo.com explore
more
cultural burning is pretty
straightforward it's lighting
low-intensity fires which burns up the
fuels in the forest and helps living
things there regenerate
ankili says that the kuruk yurok and
hoopa tribes in northern california have
been burning the land for 13 000 years
like back in the day i think estimates
are that about eight million acres of
california was burned every year in
these cultural burns these you know
low-intensity burns in fact they've been
doing it for so long
that there are certain species of tree
that a lot of the pines there for
example can't germinate unless um they
are the cones are opened by fire and you
might think oh well that's because it's
evolved alongside wildfire but that's
not to be true if you think about it a
wildfire is so hot that when it comes
through it'd burn up the cones and it
would burn up the seeds as well which is
amazing to think about how long that's
been happening for cultural burns can
change the environment in pretty
dramatic ways
basically the air turns the smoky dark
gray and the sun turns into this red
thing and it looks like the end of the
world
and that can have some fascinating
effects on animals like salmon
salmon need cold water to migrate and
research suggests that the smoke from
cultural burns may actually cool the
rivers that they swim through they're
talking about
using the smoke from the cultural birds
to specifically to help the salmon on
their trip up
it's an amazing thing
i mean it's all another thing
everything's interrelated you know so
it's hard when you start talking about
these single-issue things especially
with indigenous knowledge it's so
holistic everything is related to
everything else the cultural burning is
related to the removal of the dams
saving the salmon the fire all of it's
all related you know so super cool
for thousands of years indigenous people
manage forests land and other natural
resources in the americas and developed
what's known as traditional ecological
knowledge
then european settlers arrived and
keeley says that initially they weren't
opposed to cultural burns
people even way back when in the 1800s
and 1700s
actually knew that indians were burning
and a lot of them actually saw the
wisdom in doing that kind of burning
nonetheless europe had a cooler and
wetter climate that didn't really depend
on fire the way areas of the american
west or australia do and as settlers
moved west they and their descendants
became concerned about fires damaging
their homes farms and businesses
that along with the forest removal of
native american tribes from their
ancestral homelands led to a decline in
cultural burning activity in the 19th
century
then in the early 20th century there was
a major event that really became the
turning point for how americans viewed
fire
the great fire of 1910 also known as the
big blow up or the devil's broom fire
burned over 3 million acres of the
rockies killing 78 firefighters the u.s
forest service had just been formed a
few years prior in 1905.
the agency received a lot of attention
for how it responded to the great fire
of 1910 and emphatically pursued a
policy of fire suppression officially
the forest service stance became
to avoid burning
avoid doing that kind of burning
precisely because the indians were doing
it
burns of all kinds including cultural
burns were suppressed in law and culture
like in 1944 when the u.s forest service
created the mascot smokey bear to
promote forest fire prevention
you know i had read that that campaign
is like it's the longest running
american public service announcement
it's really fascinating how long that
messaging has sort of been
pervasive in our society yeah i think
that um the smokey the bear is a funny
kind of relic of a bunch of things you
know it started out with a sort of
racist notion that they were doing
something and thus we shouldn't do it
but you know i think um even more than
that that there's sort of a deep-seated
cultural bias among what westerners in
general i would say is a fear of fire
fire is this big scary thing even
europeans almost certainly used cultural
burning at some point in time but they
forgot you know and then it became a
scary thing
to be clear it's not that people who
invented smoky were necessarily thinking
about cultural burns it's more that
smoky reflected this larger fear of fire
among the american public
and also you have smokey the bear and
very much a educational
paradigm of you know only you can
prevent wildfires and so much of that
wildfire narrative has been at the
expense of indigenous peoples cultures
and being able to use fire that's frank
lake an ecologist for the u.s forest
service who studies climate change
wildland fire ethnoecology and
traditional ecological knowledge he
actually worked on the study looking at
how cultural burns might affect salmon
and he's a member of the kuruk and urak
communities
so i grew up a lot around that tension
between the federal government and local
tribes around environmental and resource
management around the effects of fire
exclusion and fire suppression and heard
the stories oh our people used to burn a
lot more we're dependent upon fire for
healthy wildlife like the deer and elk
we would hunt the connection between
water is sacred and by burning to reduce
the plants or the trees that use up the
water
i take it that most people maybe of your
generation older have not seen very many
cultural burns is that right that's
correct
coming up after the break we'll get into
how one wildfire devastated a carrot
community and meet a woman who's leading
the way in training the next generation
of fire lighters
over the years that cultural burning has
been suppressed wildfires have become
more frequent and destructive
in the 1990s wildfires burned an average
of 3.3 million acres a year
that rate more than doubled in the 2010s
during which wildfires burned an average
of 7.5 million acres a year
many of these impacted areas are in
california and they often hit
communities where native people live
you also have the tribes here who lived
with uh
some of the highest densest levels of
smoke and emissions
where you had severe air quality days
that were so bad that they had to
develop like a new chart for relating
how how dangerous and how thick the
smoke was imagine being an elder with
emphysema or
other heart and lung complications and
then now you have a power outage you
can't run the air purifier you don't
have air conditioning you're breathing
smoke you're a disadvantage a low income
family so you can't be smoke refugees
and go out to the coast or get a hotel
someplace else
you have to stay here and eat it
in the fall of 2020 keely went to happy
camp a town with many kuruk residents it
had just been devastated by the slater
wildfire which burned nearly 200 homes
many of which belonged to kuruk families
i mean even massive trees were
completely torched you know were burned
to cinders and structures were stat only
just just metal was standing there were
tons of vehicles that were just pulled
off the side of the road that there was
nothing left
yeah it was incredible to see the the
level of devastation of it and yeah it
looked like
an apocalypse to come through
keely was traveling with a kuruk friend
who lived there and was seeing it for
the first time in person
when we got out of the car we were
looking at this devastation this burned
out hulk of a wreck of our of the
vehicle and um nothing left of a
structure except some tin
sheets on the ground that were all
burned up and the first thing she did
was she hauled out a bucket from the car
and asked her i was like what's in the
bucket you know and and she started
tossing acorns around and she said
this is an opportunity this is an
opportunity for
uh me to heal the land by planting these
acorns here you know i'm right here in
this place originally there weren't that
many oaks this is a chance for us to
heal the land and
she said also
that in healing land and planting the
acorns and doing cultural burning all of
this is also a chance for me to heal
myself
in your conversations with you know
members of the kuruk and yurak tribes
like how do how do people talk about
fire and what can we learn from these
tribes about how we should think about
fire you know like my friend ron told me
that when he was a kid
you know his grandmother gave him a box
of matches one day when he was out
playing in the yard and told told him to
not come back in until he had used up
the whole box of matches
right and
yeah it's so different she was teaching
him
to not fear it and to also to how to
learn how to deal with fire you know
like clearly she wasn't afraid of the
fire and she knew that it's possible
that it could get out of control but she
would be watching and she would um she
would deal with it you know and so she
knew that by by
teaching him
very young not to fear it and how to
learn how fire works that she would be
creating someone who would keep their
culture going through cultural burning
right yeah that's sort of the antithesis
to like what i i think a lot of people
have heard when they were kids which is
not don't play with matches right
yeah right exactly that's right it's
right up there with running with
scissors
yeah don't row with scissors and don't
play with matches but i would definitely
say um
my karook norak friends would say
otherwise
to be clear keely isn't encouraging kids
to play with matches it's more about
encouraging kids to have a healthy
relationship with fire
even though there's no absolute way to
control fire healy says the damage that
a cultural burn could cause would be
small compared to a wildfire and there
is a greater risk to consider in not
burning the land regularly
when a wildfire does actually go through
and you've missed the chance to stop
that wildfire that wildfire is going to
destroy
way more way more than a cultural burn
ever would in a cultural burn something
gets out of control and you know you
burned out a couple of houses by
accident or something like that when the
wildfire comes through that entire place
is just burning to a cinder there's not
going to be anything left entire
settlements entire towns are going to be
burned to a crisp like in paradise
california where
everything's gone and it's unrecoverable
according to the u.s forest service 99.8
percent of prescribed burns stay where
they're supposed to the agency is
currently reviewing its approach to
prescribe burns
i i definitely think that cultural
writing is a real legitimate tool it's
one of the few
legitimately scalable tools that we as
human beings as a species have to
actually combat things like climate
change you know it's it's an amazing
tool
fire is also necessary for indigenous
tribes to carry on their traditions
margot robbins a yurok tribe member is a
basket weaver so she depends on cultural
burns in order to grow basket weaving
materials
when our babies are born
we carry them in baskets we use baskets
to cook eat
carry things
and
we
use baskets to lift up prayer
and finally when our time on this earth
is done we
send off the person's spirit by feeding
them on a basket
the basket's margo weaves are made of
california hazelnut on its own hazelnut
grows into a bush but when you burn it
every now and then new shoots come up
straighter and stronger excellent basket
weaving material
up until 10 years ago government
officials wouldn't allow margot to burn
the land
there's no paper any place in existence
that says we gave up our right to use
fire in recent years the forest service
has come around to seeing the value of
cultural burns but to conduct a cultural
burn you still often have to get a
permit from the government
and often emergency personnel have to be
stationed nearby in case the fire gets
out of control
very frustrating to
have to ask people who
some have never even seen our land
to get permission to burn
they don't have enough knowledge
really to be in the decision-making
place that they are
and so it's frustrating
but it is what it is
so margot started advocating for
cultural burns the movement gained steam
and she got to actually attend her first
cultural burn in 2012
one where she watched hazel burn
margo says that was the moment she
realized that it was really possible to
bring fire back
and then it really cemented our
our drive to continue to make that
happen we knew that this would be the
first of many that once we started we
would not stop that we would continue to
grow this ability to
to put fire on the lands and and that
we would have our own people from our
own homelands trained so that they could
legally
put fire on the land and not have to
risk going to prison
in 2015 marco co-founded the indigenous
people's burn network a growing
organization that works to bring
cultural burns back the organization is
made up of various native nations
nonprofit organizations researchers and
government agencies today margot doesn't
just advocate for fire she trains fire
lighters
we are teaching the next generations how
to burn
the time is long past when they shoot
people for using fire so i'm able to
take my grandkids
and my kids out
out on the land and we can burn i teach
them how to burn you
you know start at the top you bring your
fire slowly down the hill if things are
dry you put a line around it
make sure that you have water
frank meanwhile has been using a
scientific approach to advocate for
burns he has been running research to
see what the data says about the effect
of cultural burns
lo and behold that indigenous knowledge
and cultural practice usually results in
a better higher quality resource such as
acorns such as hazel shoots for basket
material such as greater berry abundance
that changes the game because now you're
saying here look at we've demonstrated
we don't need western science to
validate or substantiate indigenous
knowledge and cultural practices but it
certainly could corroborate that and say
this is where they're aligned
he's found that when groups burn
underbrush regularly the brush doesn't
build up and turn into massive wildfires
they've reduced that wildfire threat
because the wildfire burned into a
recent cultural burn and went and was
able to easier to contain
right so the more you break up the high
fuel loading areas and you reduce the
wildfire risk based on your treatments
and your prescribed fires or your
cultural burns the less you have a
wildfire risk actually threatening your
life and property in your community so
that has been demonstrated that you know
conducting multiple cultural burns or
prescribed fires in a year that can help
combat wildfires
it definitely reduces the fuels reduces
the fuel continuity of how much fuel is
there that could burn under the most
severe conditions
moderates it or reduces that fire
intensity and makes it less damaging i'm
just curious you know in the 20 years
that you've been at you know the forest
service have they become a lot more
receptive to indigenous knowledge
very much so even down to the current
administration and the council
environmental qualities direction on
indigenous traditional ecological
knowledge um the usda department of
agriculture's direction on how the
agency the particular forest service and
research and development is going to
respond to that
this year the white house announced that
it was committed to using indigenous
knowledge in policy dealing with the
relationship between humans and the
environment frank currently helps the
forest service run cultural burns
when it comes to the fall time there's
an indicator where usually the infertile
and buggy acorns brown top bad fall
first and then you start to see this
transition of the white top acorns
falling and that's our indicator locally
for burning and i try to time that just
right before the next rainstorm to burn
off clear nice little understory fire
under the acorn trees that reduces the
buggy acorns cleans up the small sticks
and leaves and then you have on that
open charred understory
white top good good acorns falling on
there that are easily obscene and picked
up
keeley actually visited one of frank's
acorn burns in the klamath river valley
you kind of like look over the klamath
river which is a river that's just sort
of like always painted with
rainbows and there's this beautiful
bright green forest full of conifers so
even in the winter time it's it's always
green he recalls what the ground looked
like after the burn was over the whole
ground was this carpet of black you know
kind of this black ash that was
has drawn everywhere and on top of it
was sitting tons of acorns and they were
all beautiful and they were like big and
plump
and none of them had any holes in them
and the thing that frank said was well
they don't have holes in them is because
the cultural fire burned up and killed
all the acorn pests we time it so that
the the acorn weevils and the acorn
moths that normally go down there they
get burned up in that cultural fire so
we time that fire just right so that it
does that and then you know while we
were there we gathered a bunch of acorns
to take home to make into food
frank says that it's important his kids
understand how these fires are connected
to the food they eat and the things they
use in their house my kids see good
acorns they know what a soup tastes like
they know the deer we've hunted the nice
bucks we've shot in the areas that have
been burned they see the basket material
that made the hazel sticks for their
cradle that they were carried in
frank was partially inspired to teach
his kids about fire by visiting
australia
there he visited the martu a group of
aboriginal australians living in the
country's western desert and i got to
see aboriginal kids take a lighter and
go burn off a small patch and then i saw
the teenagers and older ones burn off a
bigger patch and then i got to go out
with the the men and burn off like a
whole big valley like we're talking like
you know a quarter mile to like a two
mile plus burn across spin effects and
through other patches of force and
shrubs
and then hunt kangaroo and so for me it
was like oh you know most of the time we
tell kids not to play with matches and
we kind of scold them and smokey the
bear says be careful of fire but we need
to teach our kids to respect it frank
thinks kids need to start off with that
mindset when they're young kids help
burn sometimes my kids are in fifth
grade and third grade they really talk
about it um especially leland it's like
more of a matter of fact the kids like
well you just think fire is bad but
there's this this and this and there's
these plants and these are your
medicines and these are your berries and
we share those foods with the animals
and the bears and the squirrels and like
my kids can burn off a small little 50
by 100 foot area under a few acorn trees
they're to be when he's 20 or 25 years
old going to be able to carry out much
bigger landscape burns that have
multiple types of places like that right
we're going to be able to know the
direction of the wind the sounds of the
birds or the animals that are there that
are indicators you're going to know when
it's the right time to use fire in the
best way in a good way for safety for
security and to the benefit of again
your family and the community yeah i
have to say i love the idea of like
you know your kid teaching other kids
about the value of fire
it's really great they need to and
particularly with what we see in the
news and how sensationalized the
catastrophic fires
we need the hope stories right we need
to know that there is a positive
relationship that people can have in
living with fire
if you like what you hear and want to
support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
fuel your curiosity with a digital
subscription to national geographic it
gives you unlimited access to unique
perspectives and stories published daily
on science history animals and more
subscribe for 2.99 cents a month at
natgeo.com
explore more
cultural burns are just one of many
stories that keeley and writer charles
mann covered about the ways indigenous
groups are trying to reclaim sovereignty
that's coming out in the july issue of
the magazine
and if you want to hear more from keeley
you can also listen to a previous
overheard episode where he shares
stories about the many weeks he spent
camping on sea ice with native alaskan
whale hunters
if you're dying to see his photography
check out his website to see portraits
of indigenous people arctic wildlife and
more
also if you want to learn more about
margot robbins and her efforts to revive
cultural burns check out our article on
the subject that's all in the show notes
right there in your podcast app
[Music]
this week's episode of overheard is
produced by alana strauss our producers
are kyrie douglas and marcie thompson
our senior producers are brian gutierrez
and jacob pinter carla wells is our
manager of audio our executive producer
of audio is devar ardulon who also
edited this episode our fact checkers
are robin palmer and julie beer
our copy editors are caroline braun amy
kolczak cindy lightner and jennifer
velaga
hansdale sue composed our theme music
sound designed and engineered this
episode
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners the national
geographic society committed to
illuminating and protecting the wonder
of our world funds the work of national
geographic grantee keely rhian
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences nathan
lump is national geographic's
editor-in-chief and i'm senior editor
and host eli chen thanks for listening
and see y'all next time
[Music]
[Music]
you